the second you fall asleep it all just
goes back to the start I drove all the
way back home to Austin and I still woke
up here one time I smoked a bunch of
crystal and made it all the way to
Equatorial Guinea it was a huge waste of
time this movie obviously takes place in
an infinite time loop so what's one
ridiculous thing that you would do if
you were stuck in an infinite time would
probably just a lot of drug-related
stuff I was gonna say I was gonna try I
would try every drug lad
you know you can do things and then the
next morning there's no repercussion
right huge part of my fear is like I
would get addicted problems are like
this would be a way to truly take away
all the negatives I think that that and
then depending on where I was like I
would probably try to like I don't know
why this answer is coming to my brain
because it's weird but like I would try
to like different wild animals I would
wonder if the drug hangover would like
then translate into the next day but
yeah so down for that one um I know that
most of this movie isn't improved but
Kristen I've been watching a lot of your
interviews and I heard you say in wine
that one of your favorite scenes in this
movie is completely ad-libbed
so it's hoping you can tell us what that
scene is and why it is your favorite
well it's not entirely ad libs but what
I do with one of the lines was not part
of it and that was because I wanted to
get a reaction out of Andy it's the it's
the it's the hook scene and I wanted to
like you know that part wasn't planned
like what I'm wearing and like what I
how I say it and like I can't remember
and maybe some of its improvised but
like that was always part of it was that
like he was the hero of the scene I was
the villain or whatever and it's one of
my favorite because like I don't know I
grew up watching Beetlejuice that was
like a deeply seminal film for me and
like any time that I'm allowed to just
like completely go nuts and like get
weird and wild it's like that's what I
have been dreaming of doing since I was
a kid I would do a home movies that
character yeah what was your favorite
improv moment in the film
at one point I ripped my shirt open and
Kristen just goes nice I think it says a
trailer now that's like the reaction you
want you know I feel like if you're a
guy and you just take your shirt that's
like that dream reaction you know when
Pete I'm so obsessed with this film like
when people asking about it I'm like
it's like an effed up 50 first day to me
it's Groundhog Day meets Russian doll Oh
both of you
inspired by these classic time-loop
movies and why do you think people love
them so much I mean I my own personal
I've never seen Groundhog Day but I have
seen wish I was a huge Russian doll fan
I think what's a doll is like incredible
yes I think it's because we're like all
revisiting this thing of like that no
matter what our circumstances are we
can't escape ourselves and I think
that's like what makes them all so
special personally um yeah I think that
combined with the fun and games of no
repercussions yes such wish fulfillment
there which is a very like studio thing
to say but like it's true and you want
something it kind of makes you feel like
a little kid where you're you're
actually free to try crazy [ __ ] again
yeah well then it's not gonna actually
hurt anyone or have harmful
repercussions in the long term letting
go thinking ahead is such a something
that we all wish we could do as adults
right just like living with no regrets I
totally agree it's like the ultimate
freedom they're wrapping me up so I have
to know before I go
what would Peralta from Brooklyn
nine-nine and Tracy from How I Met Your
Mother
what's the most ridiculous thing they
would do in an infinite time loop I
don't know what was her vibe no I'm
trying to think I was gonna be like can
I pick a different character like I was
like trying to think of like one a one
someone I've played that would like
really light [ __ ] up I think like the
woman I played in Black Mirror I mean
that was also like I guess actually like
a version of a time loop but she really
she doesn't suffer fools I feel like she
would do some like
incredible stuff yeah the two of them
would probably end up on a pretty cool
adventure yeah both problem-solving
personalities yeah a lot of sleuthing
yeah lots of sleuthing there's a bomb in
the cake don't worry I used to be a bomb
guy my first question to you is what's
one ridiculous thing you would do if you
were stuck in an infinite time what
wouldn't I do I mean something super
dangerous yeah I would do something
dangerous I think living without fear
because you know something you know
you're gonna get you're gonna get pulled
out of it living without fear would be
incredible like I feel like I wouldn't
be scared to do skydiving now you honest
with people and stand up for people that
were being shitty yeah it's fine I think
I think I'd try to get more fistfights
because I would be scared of getting
injured but I feel like you know so like
I've never gotten to do that not that I
you know silence but like I want to be
able to defend myself and like punch
someone back if they attack you know to
me I want that confidence to be like oh
yeah I walk up to like any guy I feel
like I just have no fear at that point
luckily well because this movie takes
place in an infinite time loop what was
it like shooting scenes over and over
again and was it ever confusing because
I'm assuming like most films you're
shooting things out of order so was that
hard for you guys to wrap your heads
around I think because most things chew
on a border it wasn't that strange but I
think it's also pretty easy to remember
because every you'd be like oh this is
the night of the wedding when there's a
bomb in the cake or this is the night of
the wedding when Andy asks Baba blah
blah like I think there's just as long
as you can remember that one specific
situation that happens on that one night
then you were good yeah and the context
and the situations are so crazy like
with the bomb and the cake stuff that
you're just kind of reacting to what
going on yeah he went at Niles Andy's
character is like acting bizarre to me
as his girlfriend it's kind of like she
has no idea she's in a loop
she's just every day is just the same
for her and some yeah yeah it was
weirdly not them expense Meredith your
character I just have to say anything
you ever play it's just such a blast to
watch because you commit so hard I was
wandering watching this film you know
did you have to cry over and over again
or did you do it once and then they just
played that scene over I probably did it
in a few cheeks I think these are the
one when I pride in him that ones that
team yeah I think I probably did it a
couple times I can't quite remember if
it was and over and over again I think
it wasn't a very long scene it's the
scenes that you do and I'm sure Camila
can relate to this that are like three
page priors that's like getting there
every time but yeah I think we did it a
few different ways but we moved pretty
fast still was an indie movie so you
were kind of we were kind of wow it
sounds grueling mo it's like a very like
grueling schedule you're grueling feels
more fun and quick paying it's nice to
have a fast pace cuz you're like try to
beat the clock and everyone's like all
right game time alright nice well kami
there's a question I wanted to ask you
that I feel like most people are gonna
be thinking after they finish watching
this film we wanted to know what did the
character Sarah whisper to your
character and then what did Kristin the
actress actually whisper to you on set
because there's a very lost in
translation moment whew I wonder what
she actually said to me that I don't
remember okay um but I mean what I think
was pretty clear the movie was that
she's whispering the secret that she
well I'd want to stay cuz I don't want
it to be in the interview and ruined a
surprise so yeah I can't say it cuz it's
gonna ruin the whole list of the movie
yeah yeah yeah I can't reveal that
I respect I respect that honestly it's
we all love you on Riverdale so much it
was really cool to see you in this what
was it like not playing a teenager
how did you approach this character
differently when I found in talking my
other interviews is that veronik is
actually kind of like a little adult I
think all the characters in Riverdale
are kind of like mini adults
I mean Veronica runs three businesses
and like she's I don't know she's just
such a boss that I feel like she acts
like an adult as it is so it didn't feel
super different if anything it felt more
different to play a different kind of
personality you know someone who is a
little bit softer everything that we are
doing together is meaningless
meaningless at least you have each other
nothing worse than going through this
[ __ ] alone
[Music]